mathieu oui il ya une personne qui l'a
annoncé si c'est une très belle surprise
pour moi je ne rigole pas aulas ça
offert extrêmement plaisir c'est ça la
salamandre 10 secondes ont posé deux
questions à l'ombre chinoise ouais ya
une ombre ouais lé chinois
wei voir si tu nous as
well as vous répondre avec la modifier
pour savoir qui est votre surprise ce
soir oui quelqu'un que vous aimez
énormément c'est pour conducteurs cette
histoire rien d'une surprise
oui savait avant de découvrir ce cas
dans l'oeuf il faut le casser baboo
surtout connaître la poule
je parle de kinder co na
[Musique]
waie pas de projet vidéo question on
branche chinoise et une annexe
ça réduit beaucoup de monde
[Applaudissements]
je préfère
la lada combien la coupe de cheveux
c'est encore un petit peu on branche
chinoise et ulrich
nom alors je ne connais pas
[Applaudissements]
or c'est une erreur
voilà c'est une erreur matthieu
delormeau il a une magnifique surprise
pour vous derrière wayne a pas d'arrière
oui oui expression il ya une magnifique
surprise je vous jure c'est quelqu'un
que vous aimez énormément 1 qui a
souhaité venir vous faire une
déclaration annonçant à
la fois est-ce que actuellement d'idées
mathieu vous êtes en bail avec quelqu'un
au nom de connery non mais dis non à
gros seins d'être en bas y'a quelqu'un
chébran à quelqu'un je suis je suis en
[Musique]
bas répond ça va
vous avez concrétiser ah oui
oui tu es en couple ou pas au maire
d'aulnay
n'était pas clair oui oui non c'était
pas qui s'est concrétisée tu es en
couple c'est normal tu as tout y est
passé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais oui je vous le dit mathieu oui
mathieu déjà première question ouais je
la pose à tous oui je préfère qu'elle
est là qu est la personne sur qui vous
comptez le plus ici déjà un temps
lecture qui vous comptez le plein nature
vous dire bon dernier parce que c'est
quelqu'un sur qui vous avez compté des
années et des années valérie benaïm il
ya deux personnes oui géraldine et vous
vers sa famille castaldi ça y est vous
bien évidemment merci vous bien éprouvée
pernikoff à ça me fait plaisir pour lui
[Rires]
reviendra de la semaine proche et cette
semaine on y viendra avec nouveau
bredouille
intérêts gilles et bernard à bercy pour
moi une âme young gilles méhu la lumière
pour moi c'est kelly voilà kelly avec
kelly je suis en cet égard n'est pas de
prendre le lampadaire dans les deux
bouts alors outre vous quitterez vous
même
et éventuellement gilles quand même
bernard montiel isa et kelly vraiment
c'est de ces deux ambiances différentes
oui les agréables et de tels cas sont
agréables
à papa mathieu déjà valérie et valérie
merci
finie la chine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
salut
et vous cyril à part michel qui d'autre
je vous dis la vérité moi je compte
ici à nana na na chn/n moi qui ai dit je
m'étonne qu'il dit parce que ma famille
donc là si je me voyais bien oui bah oui
mais la chose ça fait plaisir je ne vous
mets plus castaldi quoi merci valérie
bénaïm bien sûr mon guillaume d'amour
vers 6-7 rôle à la voile mais c'est
clair mais jamais avec lui c'est
isabelle eschyle oui batum montiel je
compte sur lui également ah oui tout le
monde il faut qu'ils comprennent ce que
vous avez mis tout le monde sur ce match
c'est vrai ton mouton c'est lui qui aime
tout le monde aime personnes patrick
bruel album non mais là moi j'aime pas
tout le monde sur vous
[Rires]
parce que vous sortez la concurrence
j'aurais tout mc n 11 bat de du métier
de l'année de l'animation de la des
médias allaient
mathieu oui donc voulu parler dans
l'équipe uniquement non on s'en fout ou
dans tout la vie dans toute la vie à
deux personnes qui comptent le plus dans
toute ma vie oui c'est particulier ça
mais je dirais
je dis je dirais mon ami paul j allais
vous haussez bon choix si les deux
qu'ils ont fait à ma carrière
l'intérieur bon parcours
des parcours de carrière j'en ai pas
mais partie oui c'est vrai passé les
clubs à une carrière de six mois
terminés sur des grands prime time pour
toi
et je ne rigole pas ah ah oui oui bon tu
vas peut-être personne derrière ce n'est
ni moi ni marc olivier fogiel oui parce
que je suis je n'ai pas le don
d'ubiquité non oui et on voit bien que
c'est pas marc olivier fogiel non non je
vous aime beaucoup n'auraient pas trop
vu je faire un petit jeu comme ça
+ matthieu delormeau dans un instant moi
j'ai une idée vous allez voir qu'il
salue c'est une énorme surprise c'est
pas une vanne non ce n'est pas une
tribune j'ai pas vu depuis un moment oui
c'est pas si attention ces motifs mois
ah ouais je sais vous êtes émotif oui et
le meut et le monsieur joue de la flûte
1 alors la flûte match est pas l intrus
dans son micro et un micro
[Applaudissements]
ouais
à
dieu
[Applaudissements]
oh
du coup je l'est maintenant di luca le
gall heugas et ocarina
mathieu voici ta surprise c'est papa
christian morin du couple mais sans
rigoler
bravo marion van ouais franchement bravo
pour votre perspicacité et j'ai ce que
vous êtes heureux d'être revenus dans
l'émission
très c'est vrai non vraiment on s'était
vus alors matthieu delormeau et moi mais
c'est un peu comme comme une histoire
d'amour c'est comme l'histoire minecraft
une histoire bien sûr professionnel
séparé lionel way professionnel et un
signal social elle plus professionnel et
c'est vrai que tous les deux ou ça
tournait autour pour qu'ils reviennent
c'est rien c'est
non non non c'est rien c'est assez monde
mathieu je rappelle juste avant
d'envoyer un petit sms oui oui toi un
autre oui mais je t'ai laissé un petit
peu marine et mais tu m'as réécrit
et on s'est vus et
au départ on n'osait pas se taire et
chausse oui c'est vrai mais quand même
il ya mon fils qui est arrivé
et m'a dit tu vas pas prendre de l'ombre
seulement
ces
histoires r oui c'est vrai 1 pourquoi tu
dis ça jure il est très gentil suis pas
d'accord c'est gamana
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il m'appelle de connard
quand nino était vraiment tout petit est
ce que vous vous rappelez que cyril
l'entraînait à mettre des coups de pied
à mathieu congrès des choux
non mais vous adore la médaille d'or ils
l'adorent et je lui rend bien
c'est ce qui fait des tables oui c'est
vrai que c'est le petit qui fait les
tables mais ça reste aussi sur coup ce
match c'est sûr c'est sûr qu'à mon avis
ce môme n'aime pas perdre et qu en ce
moment
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu nous fais
joe jonas
parvenir si on vient là dessus
il revient là là là voilà genre demain
méchoui gens hautement ou après demain
ou vendredi oui mais à mes yeux
ou parier qu'il sera là avant la fin de
la semaine ah bah c'est sûr alors mais
la ville attention attention j'ai dit là
dans les locaux
ne peut pas dire tous les deux on sera
là sur le plateau nicolas d'or mais
voilà alors mathieu
[Rires]
non mes produits
nicolas
regarder justement est-ce que vous êtes
fidèle en amitié comment vous êtes
fidèle en amitié au jeu fidèle dans tout
quand vous avez travaillé à quelqu'un tu
nombreuses années ce que vous prenez
tout le temps de ses nouvelles ah non ça
se précise j'ai l'impression que non non
oui oui non mais oui après il est
franchement l'année où on s'est pas vus
tous les deux on sait pas beaucoup écrit
c'est pas pour autant qu'on n'aime plus
les gens oui alors il me répondait même
peu mais c est m non j'ai pris un petit
peu de recul ça va j'ai appris un petit
peu dans l'air c'est pas du recul c'est
un radar d'euros
à mes yeux une phrase qui m'avait
beaucoup touché et qui m'a fait revenir
c'est le jour où je suis parti ouais
vous m'avez dit ça c'est vrai vous
m'avez dit écoute je comprends que tu as
besoin de partir un petit peu mais sache
que ta chambre sera toujours là c'est
mignon qui quittent l'appartement mais
ta chambre te mangerai pas audi dont
sabah et ouais tu peux venir écouter un
moment d'émotion tu peux plus drôle ici
l'émotion la révolution a atteint sauva
si vous votiez elles sont toujours en
émotions et en voilà
non je prends des nouvelles des genres
et bien sûr il ya une personne ici oui
qui est venu vous voir ses collègues
avec qui vous avez travaillé de
nombreuses années pas quoi un collègue
un collègue avec qui vous avez farine
nombreuses années ça devient très bien
présenté le le mag mag oh là là non pas
le mad mad mad max ça marchait pas moi
j'ai présenté le mac à l'internet mobile
il marchait pas non plus gestion
[Rires]
et le magnifique renner je peux vous
dire que ça va beaucoup mieux que
influence à bas
heureusement heureusement qu'ils ont
jean-marc sur la chaîne sur nrj 12 on
cartonne mais sinon le reste est vrai
que c'est un peu plus compliqué mais
c'est vrai que ça marche beaucoup mieux
qu'en flandre et j'ai vu d'ailleurs les
scores du mas de mingue et je vais
délaisser leurs voeux encore ça je peux
vous dire qu'il serait content puisque
la ccda des captations je serai ravi de
l'orpailleur influence n'est plus non
la personne qui est là ce soir c'est
quelqu'un qui en a gros sur la pomme de
terre
la patate la bintje
excuses à
l'échangé de pommes de terre nouvelles
moi je connaissais
non moi salles de l'île de ré jeu
non mais c'est un moment où vous allez
prendre vraiment une pomme de terre
mérité
un mélo toujours pour la pomme de terre
de l'île de ré
jeu ça rigolo mois normé tiennent
vraiment montiel je confirme vraiment je
sais que la phase 2 qui va prendre
pernikoff
[Rires]
c'est sûr je suis au japon il prendra la
place du mondial c'est sûr elle
dédicaçait line audois
mathieu mathieu la personne oui c'est un
ami que vous aimez mais j'espère si je
vous dis
dominique
strauss kahn
la flûte ou dominique c'est pour la
flûte et je peux vous demander justement
des jeux demandé à quelques personnes
pour ce moment d'émotion de vraiment de
bien vouloir la mettre en veilleuse
je parle bien sûr de kelly de bernard
montiel isabelle mercier ni ben
justement petit
jeu sobre en continu
garde ne gardons que valérie bénaïm
giratina
vous
donc le nécessaire
et j'ai couché que les allemands - non
mais vous voyez rien de
[Rires]
spécial et garder cette surprise à vous
faire plaisir pour vous et pour mathieu
oui
je sais c'est sérieux le savait oui
c'est qu'il est prononcé et ça me touche
beaucoup parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
effectivement c'est une vraie surprise
oui oui et c'est quelqu'un qui a connu
un moment très difficile dernièrement je
sais qu'ils vous adore matelas ne râlent
tout le temps de vous et j'adore je suis
fan de lui je voulais même le recruter
en chroniqueur absolument inédit une
fois exactement oui mais oui je pense
qu'il aurait été extraordinaire
il a refusé je ne sais pas je ne sais
plus ce super du nord mais en fait c'est
pas ça s'est passé je ne sais pas pour
quelle raison oui ça aurait été le 82e
chroniqueur de saison mais s'arrêter ça
aurait été bien c'est moi non mais
j'aime beaucoup et je vois qu'il sait
c'est que les gars étaient sur nrj12 et
que effectivement qui est un ami que
j'adore et que je vais voir ce week end
oui et c'est vrai qu'on s'est pas vu
depuis un petit moment et c'est de ma
faute et je m'en veux parce que et lui
paraît bien sûr je lui parlais il est
avec nous ce soir dominique damien réhel
merci
donner l'occasion bien sûr les cajole
indexé bon année les spectateurs c'est
vrai que vous avez été ensemble sur le
mag oui c'est vrai que dominique c'est
que j'étais fan de toi je suis toujours
sévère allait proposer de venir je sais
de tir deux mois serait dommage ça donne
moi ta fluxa
dominique c'est vrai que je sais qu'il
ya eu des moments difficiles oui qu'est
ce qui s'est passé quand arrêter le
madman le mag qui s'est passé non moment
disons que quand il ya une kobe d' way
to c'est complètement décalé ça veut
dire que bon j'avais beaucoup moins de
déchets n'est pas ce que je faisais
beaucoup beaucoup de décider avant tout
me rappelle il fait des défis d'un coup
de chaud je fais pas que de la télé j'ai
aussi un travail que je fais déjà
organisé des filets je monte des défilés
donc tout s'est arrêté à cause du
comique puis je ne pouvais pas faire les
fashion week il est des filets le
festival international des jeunes
créateurs de mode qui organise depuis de
nombreuses années c'est raté aussi donc
tout s'est arrêté à beaucoup moins de
propositions beaucoup moins de travail
j'ai su rentrer dans une grande déprime
ces jeunes très grande dépression et
j'ai fait on a testé un burnout et c'est
vrai que j'ai pendant cette période la
hache et d'action puisse résoudre ce que
je vois mathieu cette fois qu'on s'est
pas vu et c'est mon ami je l'aimais
énormément et c'est vrai et donc je suis
tombé dans une période où ça n'allait
pas bien du tout donc j'ai pas buzzé un
petit peu bas budget pas un petit peu et
j'ai abusé des médicaments beaucoup pour
nerveusement tenir le coup j'en ai pris
un petit peu beaucoup et puis un jour je
me suis pas réveillée pendant deux jours
donc et c'est vrai que pendant ces
moments là ça devrait quelques temps je
commence j'appelais pardon en actions
j'appelais souvent mathieu les messages
et pour des raisons attend si je peux le
faire culpabiliser à c'est vrai c'est
vrai qu'à ce moment là je n'ai pas
répondu ballard est pas du tout parce
que je sais que mon amitié pour lui et
les indestructibles et il me répondait
pas bien pas que je veux dire y'a pas
que toi dans l'avion n'a pas beaucoup
d'amis on a très peu d'amis dont il fait
partie de mes amis et j'ai eu très peu
de personnes à ce moment là qu'on était
présent
alors donc là je gardais mon ami mathieu
qui ne répondait pas alors je perdais
tout donc là un moment donné j'ai perdu
pied heureusement allez mon fils louis
oui que j'embrasse très très très fort
qui m'a aidé après avoir fait c'est à
dire cette bêtise de bain ne pas se
réveiller pendant deux jours ça fait
drôle on a besoin des deux c'est comme
en guerre un suicide quelque part si je
n'aime pas dire ce mot est peut-être
fort mais c'est ça donc j'ai réussi à
remonter un peu la pente doucement ma
boîte de nuit jamais j'ai même
discothèque mais on connaît les
problèmes des discothèques on est en
train se sont échappées d'abord alors
c'est une bonne minute jallet à saint
malo qui s'appelle ben ce club et même
niveau plus donc je n'ai plus attendons
donc j'ai arrêté le ben parce que bon ça
peut était possible il y avait un bail
dérogatoire s'arrêter j'ai tout arrêté
j'ai pas pu continuer et donc tout s'est
écroulé tout s'est arrêté plus de
défiler plus de balles et de la mois
plus rien tous ces téléphones ne sonnent
plus d'un cycle à la belle à ces cas là
tu as oublié de tout le monde
donc tu te casses la gueule complètement
j'ai pu fait pu m'accrocher nulle part
et la tuile hd mieux est contents de
nous voir ça tirait quand j'étais comme
ça quand il me parle tout le temps
dehors je sais que je t'adore mais moi
aussi je le sais je l'aï toujours dit et
je voulais même que tu viennes autour de
la table est un personnage incroyable
mais je sois tu voulais dire quelque
chose à mathieu parce que tu l'as pas vu
depuis longtemps et je sais que tous les
deux c'est une très grande amitié mais
dire que je suis sans les murs canon
mais ce que je sais c'est juste que
c'est vrai que l'année dernière c'est
fou comme de ses missions du tout la
dernière que j'ai arrêté l'émission j'ai
arrêté tout c'est à dire que c'est vrai
que c'est pas beaucoup répondu à toi
j'ai pas beaucoup répondu à dominique
c'est vraiment une année où j'ai hâte et
m'ont un peu la télé ça m'a fait un bien
fou s'est jamais été aussi en forme que
cette année mais c'est vrai que j'ai
arrêté un petit peu tous en avaient
besoin moi j'en avais besoin pendant le
coït c'est vrai que pendant le coït
quand on s'ennuyait dans les
appartements souvent dominique
m'appelait hilali va bien et puis après
le qu'ovide et puis quand j'ai pris mon
année sabbatique c'est vrai que j'ai pu
beaucoup répondent au téléphone à
personne et je m'en veux parce que ben
voilà on est passé près d'une
catastrophe oui donc
je sais très lâche c'est ce que j'aurais
fait la passe au papa je vais faire des
armées mais mais c'est vrai que c'est à
deux doigts alors après j'ai remonté la
pente doucement le ans après les choses
sur commence à revenir là je pourrais
parler de mon festival quand même parce
que c'est ça qui me fait aussi avoir des
projets cet appui de projets que t'as
plus rien et tu t'accroches à rien il
faut avoir des projets alors sophistes
et les conséquences ducobu dont on ne
parle pas beaucoup mais elles sont là
aussi pas je dire il n'y a pas c'est ça
aussi des gens qui ont tout perdu gemini
qui a pu la télévision il ya plus les
ordres ça s'est arrêté l'été dedans y'a
pus nrj12 ya plus sa boîte de nuit il ya
plus de festival
il a un gamin qui doit qui doit voir et
nourrir c'est difficile et que ni la
paix le chômage partiel alors que moi
j'avais seize merci de le souligner pour
tous les gérants de discothèques c'est à
dire qu'on n'a pas le droit on n'est pas
interdit tant du secteur n'a droit à
rien même pas un euro ça veut dire que
j'ai vécu pendant deux ans avec les
réserves que j'avais un petit peu mais
j'ai vécu pas grand-chose l'april a
aujourd'hui à la aujourd'hui les choses
reprennent là j'ai fait quelques défilés
ça m'a permis de le remonter un pouvoir
d'un côté positif est le festival
international des jeunes créateurs de
mode que je mets en place que dans un
mois et demi qe le tout
il est dispo
que bernard connaît très bien aussi a
soutenu dans les annales icaunais du
match aussi mathieu m'a toujours soutenu
surtout les entreprises rappelait
n'était pas un indice cotées qui limite
ces vilains il m'a dit tu étais toujours
avec moi pour m'aider jamais il ya il a
manqué des buts mathieu j'ai besoin de
toi mathieu la mesure de son possible
donc voilà
le vol
pour kate il va partir dans un instant
on porte des merci parce qu'un aéroport
juste à côté lui faire un bisou mais
c'est pas mignon que tu lui a permis de
donner c'est donner parce que ça
fait